this man is a co-founder of 35
adventures and the boardroom you could
see him with Kevin Durant on ESPN plus
the fun show for you to watch right
there he is rich climbing how are you
rich I am doing fine where are you are
you calling in from New York City right
now is that where you are located where
are you located I live in New York City
but I was able to get out of the city
right now for the city but not far okay
well yeah I'm just watching and trying
to understand what's going on in the
world like everyone else okay let me let
me ask you about your client Kevin
Durant how's he feeling
what's going on with him he's good he's
out of isolation he's been cleared he
was fortunate to be symptom-free
throughout the whole process so that was
a blessing and he but he's just like the
rest of us quarantined now in kind of
regular isolation so but the the scary
part is past okay well I'm glad to hear
that
has there been any contact tracing could
he have gotten it in any way shape or
form when the NBA was active rich with
you I mean it's I think it's like too
hard to even figure out I know there was
other net players attested positive but
I think that especially being in New
York City and not even knowing how long
it could be like dormant and your system
before it gets tested or shows a symptom
and in Kevin's case never had a symptom
it's probably too hard to even figure
out okay if you don't mind before you
get into some other stuff with you just
the business of the NBA do you think as
you and I are sitting here rich that
we're gonna see games for the 2019 2020
NBA season in any way shape or form what
are you hearing what are you thinking
I'm thinking no and I'm you know I don't
know I see I understand
you know I saw Mark Cuban on the TV this
morning and I understand the thought
process behind thinking that this could
be such an important distraction of
course I understand that thought process
to a degree because in every other time
in our life we always thought of sports
is like the ultimate distraction from
something tragic but this is ongoing and
this is unknown and when you hear dr.
pouchy talk about the numbers
he's projecting it's hard to think that
this is salvageable and it's hard to
think that like some makeshift season
will do the trick and I know there's so
much money at stake and I'll leave that
to the NBA PA into the NBA but in terms
of just getting the NBA back in motion
it feels so hard to understand or wrap
your head around right now
rich climbing here on the Rich Eisen
show and one of your client Kevin Durant
is one of the few players it's going to
have 90% of his annual salary paid out
by today in this check that arrives
today I know you mentioned that the NBA
and the NBA players associate the NB the
MB PA is discussing this do you think
that there will be 25% of players
remaining salaries placed in the league
s Grove that there is going to be some
sort of force majeure what do you what
do you what are you thinking right now
rich climbing that I don't know I mean
again I think we're fortunate I was
fortunate and Kevin's fortunate to not
be in that category but you know I think
that the another thing I saw Mark Cuban
say this morning that was interesting
which is hard for people to kind of
sympathize with is that these owners
have so many other businesses that may
be leveraged in bankrupt at this time
but I think in general especially when
the idea of people talking about how it
all costs to bring these players back to
think that in the interim though we'd be
reducing their salaries and that you
know the the cabins and the LeBrons
those guys are anomalies there's players
that may be not in the position to have
something like that happened to them it
be unfortunate but it's clearly the sign
of the times right now and I could see
something like that happening he could
and would that I mean what sort of what
sort of a situation do you think that
would create would that be what you use
to describe that would be unfortunate to
be honestly I mean I think that there's
there would have to be other ways around
that in the short term right now
especially like I said when you hear
such deep conversation about how to get
these guys back on the court and you
know a lot of times we forget the
emotional side of it from players
standpoint and the psychological effect
of like they're at home with their
families too scared like the rest of us
watching this in real time on the news
and and yet there is something great
about normalcy
getting back to it and we all have to
work in some way shape or form now as
well so you know it's challenging but
it's it's it's not as easy is just like
quarantining players and getting them
back on the court to perform during the
summer it's entertainment and
distraction like I don't know how long
this will go on for none of us do you
know so I don't know it's a tricky one
but I think that I would I would hope
that at all costs we could keep that
from happening of course rich climbing
the co-founder of 35 ventures and you
can watch him and his client Kevin
Durant on the boardroom on ESPN Plus
which we'll talk about in a second right
here on the Rich Eisen show so what
advice if you know Adam Silver's door is
open and how do you think the NBA should
proceed right now rich I don't know I
don't have that answer I honestly don't
and I think that's probably why Adams
door is open and he's listening to you
know the different owners and players
and the union reps I mean it's a tricky
one because when there's such fluid
information in the world it's not like
there's any true word from any
government official obviously but I do
know that the players are stepping up as
they always do and you see it on social
media write it on traditional media that
more so than any other group of people I
it seems to me that NBA players have
such a good pulse on the world a lot of
times and are able to kind of step up
and be a voice of calm and give back
always and you know a lot of times you
see it you see them talking about it but
there's a handful of players that don't
feel the same need to always talk about
it that are quick to activate in their
community and give back in any way they
can so I think the power of the NBA and
the power of the NBA superstars and
players is something that's important
right now and maybe if the season can't
come back on there's some way that these
media companies that have so much money
committed to the NBA and the players
themselves can come together to use that
platform to continue to give back during
this time because it's hard to imagine a
season happening it just is I hear you
man I mean you're in New Yorker just
like me and so you know what who Marbury
is clearly and not just being a New
Yorker but you're an executive producer
on a
for Marbury called a kid from Coney
Island couldn't help but notice that he
is trying to bring some much-needed
surgical masks and PPE to the New York
healthcare system what can you tell me
about Stephane and how he's working with
that and and everything else in your
relationship with him
Reggie I spoke to him this morning just
to kind of like confirm with him that
like he was so right I mean I remember
sitting with him me him and Kevin a few
days before the premiere of the movie in
Brooklyn this was like maybe the March
1st or 2nd he was just talking about how
little we were talking about the
realities of this virus and he was so
aware of what was going on in China and
had so much information it was telling
us stuff that even a month ago we were
looking at him like man that doesn't
happen over here like a month ago right
and just I had to text him today and I
saw that he had someone his family had
passed away I think it was his cousin or
something yeah and I wanted to reach out
to him and also just like to
congratulate him again on what he was
trying to do and sending these masks
back he's an incredible dude man he's so
misunderstood and I think I grew up in
New York I was a senior in high school
when he was a senior at Lincoln I
followed him all through high school any
New Yorker kind of held a different
category than than anyone else we kind
of like knew at that point in basketball
and he was already like a star to us and
when I'd opportunity to work in this
movie and Kevin and opportunity workers
movie was a no-brainer his story isn't
incredible you could have ended it
before China and the movie was
incredible and then to think that he
went over there and created this whole
world for himself and people that fell
in love with him there there's museums
built in his name and a musical that was
performed in his name I mean it's
incredible and now he's really trying to
come back and in the biggest time of
crisis it's he has this platform that he
created in China to help and it's pretty
amazing and it's amazing timing that his
movies coming out now I think it comes
out next week the 7th it'll be on Apple
he's just remarkable in the story's
remarkable you'll love it
yeah I look forward to seeing that I'm
from Staten Island so you know I would
always drive past Coney Island to visit
my
my mother's parents my grandparents on
my mother's side so I know all about
Coney Island all about the area I know
all about the Belt Parkway and all about
you know that that area and you're right
Marbury was a star well before the rest
of the country even knew about him oh
yeah you don't meet people from Staten
Island
hold on a second you don't have you
don't have you don't have outer borough
bias register actually outer borough
like fascination rich me the wu-tang
clan Alyssa Milano the list can go on
and on here Ricky Schroder okay we
expect yes rich yes I mean put us all on
the boardroom episode and watch us fly
okay that's all I'm saying
you can watch us we'll take it to we'll
take you to it'll be ESPN plus plus that
particular episode okay when did you
first meet Durant how did you cross
paths with with Kevin rich I met him his
rookie year I had a mutual friend who I
was working with in the music business
artist by the name of wale who was
coming in to see a jay-z concert he knew
I was going and he was Kevin was just
coming in with his brother so he wanted
to know if I wanted to go with him and
we met kind of hit it off we were 10
years apart in age and and we just kind
of kept in touch and talked basketball
and I was always sports junkie first
wanted to be in the sports business but
just took an unconventional route into
it so when I finally an opportunity to
start working in sports and then it was
at the right time for him making a
change in his career it was just like we
had built up that trust and that
friendship so it was kind of seamless
and to start working together what's the
most misunderstood aspect to him that
you want people to know about Kevin what
what do you got for me rich on that
front no if I want them to know but if
to answer I guess that he doesn't like I
people never believe he really doesn't
care about the things that people give
him a hard time for caring about this is
more you know the same way that there's
things that you talk about on air
during the day and it's part of your job
and right you know you get it's
entertaining and but do you care that
you hold it too close to your heart no
and it's like when he responds and
communicates with people it's I think
you know I said this the other day it's
way more a reflection of the time were
and then you know when people comment on
the fact that he's just way too
sensitive and I think it's just that's
how he how he engages and you know I
think people have learned to actually
love it and it's just kind of part of
the fabric of like what the players and
athletes and celebrities do now in
social media just was doing it first
well I don't cross I don't think cross
paths with him too many times but I just
remember her as I'm walking around the
turf or Superbowl 50 and I'm like
there's somebody in a photographers vest
who's really really tall and it was
Kevin Kevin took photographs of Super
Bowl 50 like that's that's part of his I
guess outside of basketball love's right
is photography and things like that it
was at the time you know I like it's not
that it's not it's not that rampant in
his life but it's just somebody that
like challenges himself a lot which is
helpful with our business that we built
and you know the ideas he has he always
challenges people to want to try to
bring them to fruition and I think he
was into photography and we kind of
found like an incredible outlet for it
and that was one of those like
experiences where I almost felt like
afterwards it was like okay I'm done
with photography because I just shot the
sidelines in the endzone for the
Superbowl so it's like what do I do now
you kind of reach that sports pinnacle
right when your student Superbowl 50
that's pretty much it that was
remarkable and I you know and it was
funny because after people had kind of
gotten over it for a second we're all
going back to watching the Super Bowl
because it's a Super Bowl and then you
like glanced over every so often and
it's like he's still in the endzone
sitting there shooting like laying down
next to the rest of the photographers it
was kind of amazing to watch well I look
forward to getting you seeing Kevin back
out
man look of looking forward to that I
mean I just remembered I know you know I
don't think we've ever met face to face
but I just saw your face on the screen
when Kevin's injury took place during
the NBA Finals and I just I get to see
on your face that this is serious and
and you know I wonder what that moment
was like rich that must have really just
been quite a moment for you and your and
your guy together yeah I mean before
that the energy in the stadium was I
don't know if you were at the game I was
not on TV but the energy in the stadium
was incredible and it was it kind of
felt like Daniel Larusso was gonna fight
you know like Karate Kid like he was
nice the energy was insane credible and
did you know that reference
Jeff come on man did I know the
reference I mean I just make sure I was
you're not seeing me I was painting a
fence rich I said okay yeah I got you oh
yeah I got you keep going something
interrupted it was incredible so and you
know what he he like I think everyone
saw it like that he just seemed bigger
than life when he was out there in those
first eight minutes and like hitting a
few of those shots and just it just
seemed like we were about to watch
something on another level and to have
it go from one emotion to the other so
quickly to be somebody that like on a
personal level I cared about and then to
think about how much he put into making
his decision to do it and to play and
just all of those emotions like at that
moment I think I walked
honestly walked right onto the court
like no regard for the security rules
just to kind of walk right off the court
kind of trailing behind him and you know
it was just like on a personal level
then but it quickly changed because his
attitude about it and his resilience and
his kind of ability to think about it in
the big picture and to think like okay
this is awful like this is awful but I
did what I wanted to do I'm going to
find the blessing in this and he did he
has all year in terms of like his
approach to rehab and his approach to
being a leader within the team in the
order
I think everyone's seen him on the
sidelines for most of these home games
and you know he took the challenge on
and so it was like no time to sit there
really wallow about it and look man
again we're from the same your where are
you from originally
like what's your hometown Manhattan okay
no one do you feel that way about Staten
Island you send us your garbage you send
us your garbage we'll take it and I
understand so put it all together
your client is at the forefront of a
seismic change in the basketball world
and that in that in that city I mean
nobody ever thought about the nets when
they were out in New Jersey when they're
out in Long Island maybe dr. J right now
this is a seismic change potentially in
the New York basketball scene because
your client along with Kyrie chose the
Nets rich you're aware of that right now
when it all comes down to it though rich
did he ever did he ever they ever twitch
in the direction in Madison Square
Garden they never come close I don't
know on as well no I don't think so
because I think then it's hard like I
think the first free agency it was
definitely more of one of those process
where we like the end up renting this
house in the Hamptons it was ridiculous
under that was such a it was such a kind
of like for someone like me wanted to be
around MBA we gave up his like dreams of
playing so early on to be in a room in
the hello he come in and Gregg Popovich
come in and Steve Kerr come in and all
the players come in and Tom Brady coming
it was insane I think Kevin really was
so connected to OKC but wanted to really
look at all the different options and
chose the best option for him in his
game and always relies and leans back on
I do what's best for me the basketball
player the rest will work out that's
hard for people to believe so in this
case he knows where I'm from he knows I
was a big fan growing up he knows the
teams that have caps base but he's such
locked-in competitor that like to sit
there and go back and forth with the
scenarios at 30 years old when he knew
the league so well he knew everything
and as our business has evolved we make
decisions and bigger levels and bigger
things with our
our whole company I knew how his thought
process was going to be so it wasn't
like what kind of odds we have or who
can she can he come in to pitch you was
just like let me know like here's the
info you need but I know you're doing
this your own I know you talked to the
people you need to talk to you know what
it is to play and it was I said this all
the time but then it hadn't it had more
to do with the nets and less to do with
any other teams and people wanted to
make it nicks versa nets it was just the
net they were the right opportunity and
they were in New York and there was
another team in New York who's much more
fanfare so I get it all and but that's
just not how is kind of mind works when
he's making decisions
it sounds like an episode of the
boardroom love the show man it looks
like you're enjoying it too rich I do
enjoy it I do enjoy it and we've we're
launching our podcast soon we launched
newsletter we're starting to do some
live events we did a live boardroom at
Sloan conference right before the whole
world shut down right you know really
trying to create the like this sports
business platform that is more geared
towards fans you know Sports Business
Journal has always been much more of an
industry trade and this is something
that really gives you like a look into
the realities of the sports business now
and the conversations that are happening
and the deals that are being made and
the entrepreneurs within the business
and the speed and energy of the business
and the culture around sports so it's
been exciting and there's a lot coming
and we're trying to stay very active and
give a real kind of voice to these
athletes and different entrepreneurs
during this time as well and yeah it's
cool I'm excited I'm very excited about
it everybody check it out on ESPN plus
the boardroom with Kevin Durant and
boardroom TV we have our own distributor
pardoning my dad on the boardroom TV
boardroom TV now how does all the
information all the episodes the ones
that ESPN and the ones that we put out
directly okay that's guy I want to I
want you to get the platform that you
need rich you know boardroom dot TV look
I know I love it I want to make sure I
got this thing straightened out because
I feel like we grew up together
I really do I feel like maybe we went to
summer camp together or something like
that that's what it kind of feels like
to me I went to camp Locanda and Trails
End camp where'd you go I didn't go
there but I mean I don't mean don't take
this the wrong way
great setup go [ __ ] no what what you may
be a little older than me right honey
because I I know when I was a kid I
wasn't how old are you 43 god bless you
I am older than you I already am 46
not 50 Stalin takes away four years I
guess I don't know but I did go to
school with one of Sammy the bull
Gravano is four members of his family we
all know no no I do not was that a
Goodfellas reference did you drop one
right there name is actually Karen
Gravano oh okay very go a rich love the
chat let's do this more often okay let's
do this more awesome to YouTube that's a
rich climbing right here the co-founder
of 35 ventures that was boardroom TV
boardroom goofy the boardroom tablet the
boardroom TV